than minam wrists hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Milburn and I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to episode 122 Ryan
today we're going to talk about people
people what people I don't know I
brought a list of people to talk about
today is so we're recording this early
right happy Presidents Day on this
Presidents Day I've brought you a a
life-size wax statue of Calvin Coolidge
that is the worst gift ever well and
it's melting right now hurry - I don't
know what you're supposed to do with
this wax catch you he was the minimalist
president he was the minimalist
presidents what the New Yorker said at
least yeah anyway we're recording this
actually a few weeks early because we
are headed over to Australia so by the
time this episode comes out on March 6 I
think Ryan you and I will be in the air
as this episode airs nice which is
appropriate yes we're gonna be all over
the place in Australia and New Zealand
Perth Brisbane Sydney Adelaide Auckland
Melbourne and then Melbourne again
because that first one sold out in fact
all of these are really close to selling
out at the time we're recording this a
few of them may be sold out by the time
this comes out so only a few tickets
left in Brisbane Sydney and Adelaide
Perth and Oakland a couple hundred
tickets left in both cities so those
will also likely sell out so grab your
tickets over on our website if you're
interested in seeing us that's the end
of the tour for a while we've spent a
lot of time on the road the last last
eight years gonna say like every time I
feel like we have the end of a tour I
have this like this feeling of like oh
man that tours over we're gonna relax
and then like within like 2 or 3 months
then we're planning another tour on the
road again yeah it's fun the interesting
part about all that is yeah sometimes
it's draining and it's crazy and we
overextend ourselves and we learn a lot
of lessons about overextending and then
we sort of the pendulum swings back and
the swings the other way and I
maybe after seven years it's starting to
at least end up somewhere in the middle
I agree man III think that we definitely
have been applying all the lessons we've
learned to each tour we plan so they've
been getting more smooth as they go on
but I want to say to men that like our I
guess for all intents and purposes our
business model is not touring no the
only reason we went on the less is now
tour it was because that was the right
thing to do like that was the thing that
that we could do with our time that I
felt and I think you felt would have
been the best way to spend that time
yeah I mean the documentary hit
Christmas right around Christmas of 2016
and so shortly after that it's like hey
we have this whole new audience that
we've been able to reach this year we
had a large audience before them but it
opened us up to the masses in a
different way and a different
demographic and younger people and and
just a bunch of different people who who
watch Netflix and it's like okay how do
we get this many expand on this message
a bit and going out on the road and
giving talks in front of people and
doing live podcast was a way for us to
to get this message in front of people
and a sort of visceral way like people
get out there and they read a blog post
and and a tweet rarely changes someone's
life but you can get in front of a
thousand people on a theater and Sydney
close to 2,000 people and and not
everyone is gonna walk away with like
home the sense of profundity but enough
people and it's about us being a voice
and that voice echoing through these
other voices these other people who then
become the amplifiers of the message in
a way that retweeting our message may
not you know reach I mean actually may
reach more people may not reach them
it's reaching them broadly as opposed to
going deeper and I think a lot of these
live events have allowed us to do that
yeah that said man it's been it's been
crazy difficult trying to go to 50
cities in the last year especially with
the crew and doing these big theatres
and we we worked on a model that worked
out better on paper I thought like we'd
go out every couple weeks for a long
weekend it would be like we do four
nights in a row Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday and in four cities that are
relatively close to each other but the
problem with that is
course schedules get mixed up or
whatever and you end up flying between
cities and that becomes crazy costly and
the worst is when we have an event it
goes till midnight and get back to the
hotel you know I don't get this because
I'm so wound up I don't get the safety
two or three if you're lucky right yeah
and then I've got to get up at six to
catch an 8:00 a.m. flight it's like yeah
that I mean I could do that one maybe
two nights in a row
yeah maybe two nights or over like over
and over and over yet it's it's uh it's
a little exhausting doing it down yeah
and you're by far the most durable half
you can imagine me I'm just like in
tatters and being dragged from from
place to place and so yeah we learned
another lesson and I I think you know we
did in 2014 we did the crazy hundred
City thing we realized actually there
were some good things out of that and
there were some things like well we
probably shouldn't have a year-long
sustained tour where we're literally on
the road for an entire year and then the
year after or a couple years after that
in 2016 when the documentary came out we
took a month and did fifteen cities and
that worked but it was also kind of long
a protracted approach and then last year
it's like well let's do the opposite but
then being on the road on and off all
year also didn't work out and so this
Australia New Zealand thing it's the the
end of the road for this tour of course
we're gonna do other stuff in the future
when I have no idea it'll be after a
long break and it likely won't be nearly
as expansive as before so if you do want
to see us you can come out to if you're
over on that side of the world you come
out see us and I know many of you are
asking when are we coming to your city I
don't know maybe eventually you know
we'll be back to Des Moines we'll be
back to Saskatoon hopefully we'll make
it to Berlin hopefully it will make it
to Paris yeah Winnipeg we see you you're
out there we'll find you again
Jacksonville you're somewhere you're
somewhere on the list eventually when we
have the time and when it makes sense
you know we're not just gonna tour for
the sake of touring because like you
said it's not it's not the primary
driver for doing what we do it's a great
vehicle to help get our message out yeah
I think it's allowed us to do that well
it has to make sense for us to go on
tour Matt meaning like you know not just
not just financial sense like is that
the best way we can get our message out
there is that is that the way we can
reach the most people how can
we yeah touch as many lives as possible
and if it makes sense to go to Berlin to
do that then great we'll do that but you
know right now we're focusing on that
documentary and yeah we will definitely
more tours to come so I will tell
everyone out there if you are asking
when are they gonna come to my city you
can always go to the minimalists comm
forward slash tour that will definitely
tell you exactly where we're gonna be
you can also sign up for our email list
there where we will send you lots of
spam all kinds of spam that will send
you updates and where we're gonna be
throughout the world and of course we
would never send you spam because yes
spam is gross amen
yes indeed well today we are gonna talk
about people Ryan did you blog buy a new
mattress today because all the mattress
sales are on President's Day cellphones
are on sale for Presidents Day because I
think when George Washington was like
had a founding vision for this country
it was discounted mattresses and cell
phones and cars and luxury goods man you
know it's funny cuz like it's saying all
that stuff it's actually a very American
thing I'm not saying that's a good thing
well yeah I mean American it can be used
to talk about like innovation work ethic
and a lot of positives and then also we
can use it pejoratively to say you know
overconsumption overindulgence super
abundance and it's all about it's all
about that perception and I think
sometimes you can't have the hills
without the valleys too right and I
think today when we're talking about
people we're really going to talk about
how can you be a minimalist or how can
you apply simplicity or simple living or
decluttering or simplifying to your life
and still put the important people in
your life first right and so we have
some questions that we want to want to
dive into today from from our audience
our first question is from Danny in
Lubbock Texas how do you deal with a
roommate situation I've heard y'all talk
a lot about living with a partner
um and figuring out how to work with you
being a minimalist but your partner not
so much I do to financial reasons and
probably going to be living with a
roommate here in the next couple of
months and I know that she is not a
minimalist or even close I mean she's
not a hoarder but um you don't know what
I mean anyway so my question is how do I
deal with the common areas such as the
living room in the kitchen and the
countertops on the kitchen and the
dining room and stuff like that how am I
to go about decluttering that without
stepping on anyone's toes or doing
something that would typically offend
someone if you know what I mean and I
know that my room is my room my bathroom
is my bathroom those those areas are are
easy to handle but once again it's all
about the common areas how do I deal
with how do I deal with that all right
so I think I think she Danny you have a
good firm grasp on what you do have
control over those are sort of the first
questions I asked like what do you have
control over what can you control and
it's your own areas obviously and the
good news is you have your own bathroom
that's awesome
Ryan when you and I and Colin we were
starting this business called
asymmetrical press back in 2012-2013 the
three of us moved in together for seven
months we knew as a seven seven month
experiment and I didn't have my own
bathroom no you and Colin shared one yes
we I kind of had my own bathroom you had
a for lack of a better term a [ __ ] I
mean I think it was literally a goop
hole no it was a toilet down there what
was funny about that I mean everyone a
toilet it worked okay there was a shower
down there that was like the that was
the thing I had to like be careful with
because the drain was it was really
clogged but not clogged enough to where
like the water wouldn't drain so I would
have to like basically you know take a
shower for like three to four minutes
the water would start to fill up and
then I turn the water off
it's sort of that gonna rinse off anyway
yeah that was that was a fun experiment
but but it was yours it was in Colin and
I went so so getting into this situation
so you've identified a roommate and the
first thing that I'll tell you Danny is
I know it feels like you know
considering the financial constraints
that you have right now and I'm gonna
make sure my phones on airplane mode
coded that's considering the financial
constraints that you have Danny you know
what maybe you feel like you have to
have a roommate but let me just say this
you don't have to have a roommate it may
make the most sense in your situation
and so what you're saying is you think
you've probably found an ideal roommate
and that person isn't a hoarder and
you're grateful for that and that person
may even be living intentionally and
it's just that their desires their
preferences on a living space may be
different from yours but guess what no
matter who you live with their
preferences are probably going to be
different from yours even when I live
with Colin or Ryan who the three of us
we're pretty aggressive minimalist
especially then when we owned very few
things because we knew it was like hey
this is a workspace we're gonna be
working our butts off and we're gonna
exercise and and work and that's pretty
much all we're going to do make sure we
have you know hygiene covered and and
use the bathroom and sleep and and it
was very functional for us and so it
sounds to me like Danny wants a a living
space that is going to be functional for
her but also one doesn't stress her out
right absolutely and so how do you
prevent yourself from being stressed out
well one is you have to have the right
expectations knowing knowing going into
this like hey my roommate is going to be
different from me and so knowing that he
or she will be different from you you're
asking the right questions how do I not
offend this person how do I not step on
their toes the only problem with that
question is you're asking me and Ryan as
opposed to asking your new roommate and
I think one of the first things to do is
sit down with the person and do a little
bit of standard setting a little bit of
expectation setting trying to remove
your ex phone expectations but
understand what their expectations are
and then how can you meet their
expectations because they're going to
feel more compelled to be considerate to
be conscientious to be congenial to your
needs
if if you're respectful of of their
needs ood absolutely man I'm trying to
think like what like if I was in Danny's
position what would I do I would go out
of my way to do as much as I could for
my roommate you know like showing
support and and and doing things that
that makes the roommate feel respected
likewise so let's get some let's get
tried to try to get more granular and
definitely what specific I know for me
like when I first went in there I would
actually ask those questions like how
can I avoid stepping on your toes I want
to be considerate this is our shared
living space how can I be considerate of
that space I'd go in asking those types
of questions yeah so things like well
she wants her roommate to keep the place
more tidy so step one is Danny Danny's
got to do a really good job of keeping
her things tidy yeah because that is
respecting the roommate and maybe even
say hey roommate let's say in this
hypothetical situation the the the
roommates name is Tina say hey Tina how
do i how how can I make sure that I'm
keeping up my end of the bargain how can
I make sure that this place is as tidy
as you want it to be and realizing
that's a priority for you and the way
you can express that quite often is by
making sure that you're communicating
that to someone else and saying hey I'm
trying to make sure that I understand
what your priorities are so I can meet
those priorities first yeah and usually
what's gonna happen is they're gonna
come back and say oh yeah they'll answer
your question say and then how can I
also be respectful to you yeah another
way to is not not keeping track of
things like who took out the trash last
who to last you know things like that I
think that you certainly don't want to
be in a one way street like I've been in
I've been in a roommate situation where
it was a one-way street yeah and after
trying multiple times to correct the the
relationship and trying to make it a
good living environment it got to a
point where I had to have an exit plan
and that's okay because you felt used
absolutely so I'm not I'm not telling
Danny or anyone else to just go out
there and be it you know be used but
what I am saying is is be useful and and
go out of your way to add value to the
household know and
a good way to do that is without keeping
count Lake yeah you don't want a ledger
of no relation yeah I'm trying I'm
trying to like I'm really trying to
drive this point home him because you my
best relationships the reason why they
are awesome relationships like you and I
I can't sit here and think about all
Josh you remember that one time you
pissed me off a week ago and you know
you did this or that it's like you and I
we certainly had disagreements we
certainly uh will go back and forth but
we do not hold a count I am NOT a you
know beholden to when I take action with
anything with the minimalists I am NOT
asking myself well what is Josh done
what is Sean done what is Jessica know
what it is it is not again it's not
holding account I'm really trying to
drive this point home because it's hard
to do that man it's hard I know it was
hard for me when I had a roommate and I
had to take the trash out two or three
times in a row I felt used right when I
was the only one vacuuming I felt used
and again I did get to that point where
I was being used but I've also been in
other situations where going out of my
way to not keep track to go out of my
way to add value to the situation my
roommate has reciprocated and that
happens the majority of the time I would
I would say I think so because what's
happening if you're both respecting each
other you're giving what you can give
and you're taking what you need right
and so I think maybe another thing to do
here instead of asking well how do I
make sure that the common areas are up
to my own standards or whatever how do
we maybe the better question is how can
I have helped this relationship flourish
and we start asking different questions
better questions we're gonna get better
solutions right now if the problem is
simply well it's not tidy enough for me
that then consider finding a different
roommate and and if that's the real
problem but I think the problems are
often deeper than that and the tidiness
is a symptom of something else right now
here's the thing Ryan you and I both
have roommates now we just have to
happen to be our partners right and and
and I have a four year old roommate who
is I mean she she you know if it were up
to me my standards are much different
than the four year olds right right I
spent two hours the other day getting
her to clean her room because I wouldn't
help her right I'll help give her
direction
but I'm not gonna I'm not gonna do
things for her that she can do on her
own and so instead we were supposed to
go out swimming that day and she got far
less time to go swimming because she was
throwing a fit about making her bed and
cleaning up her stuffed animals and and
putting her books back on the bookshelf
right and and that meant less time for
her and I had to sit there and it was
last time for me to enjoy it it wasn't
it wasn't me being punitive but what I
realized is yes there are when we live
with other people we have to accept the
fact that it's not going to be just my
standards that are met it's an
amalgamation of everyone else's
standards in the house and if I'm doing
my best if I'm helping the relationship
flourish then what's happening it is by
leading by example I'm raising the
standards of the household and here's
the cool thing about that when other
people special adults in the household
when I've helped raise the standard of
the household their standards are raised
and then they raise the standards even
farther which helps raise my own
individual standards now Ryan you use
this term exit plan having an exit plan
him when you had a a bad roommate and I
know the person you're talking about and
it's not that he was a bad person it
just wasn't an ideal situation for you
right and you did feel used after a
while and so I think going into the
relationship instead of having a wait to
have an exit plan maybe one of the
things that you have now is an off-ramp
you plan an off-ramp and I don't know
how long the term of your lease is but
that off-ramp could be a month from now
it could be six months from now it could
be a year from now that you know this
situation is temporary and then maybe
you can't get off immediately just like
if you're on the highway you can't
immediately swerve off the highway
without crashing but you know your next
exit is coming up and you can take that
next exit Danny so for you it may be six
months away when Ryan when you and I and
Colin all move together we knew there
was a seven seven month off-ramp and we
were gonna get off a you off of that or
we could have continued to stay on that
road it wasn't ideal for all of us
because we were going in different
directions but but it made sense for us
to have that seven month all off ramp so
if something did go wrong during the
process like all right well we know this
is temporary because on a long enough
timeline everything is temporary it
helps our sanity though to know that we
have a way out even if it's not an
immediate
way out absolutely Danny the one thing
the one last thing I want to add is when
you have conversations with your
roommate and you're asking them to help
it is very important that when you use
the word you so when you're talking to
your roommate and you're using the word
to you you are saying nothing but
compliments you're a great roommate you
have done a really good job with X Y & Z
I really appreciate you and then anytime
you want to say something negative that
is when you will use the word I you know
what I have a different lifestyle than
you I understand that I'm a bit more OCD
than you I'm so sorry about that I have
the problem not you and if you would be
willing if you such a nice person would
be willing to help me with my problem I
would really appreciate that that is
such a different approach rather than
saying you're messy you're getting on my
nerves
that is not how you're gonna win over
your roommate totally agree and so these
are my values I understand if they're
not your values I'm not trying to impose
a particular lifestyle on you I'm not
trying to force you into anything if you
have questions I'm happy to answer them
happy to be really open about it and by
the way I accept you for whoever you are
you know and and you know I'm not gonna
say warts and all but to that person
I'll allow but legitimately and that we
have to get to that that place I'm not
just tolerating the other person's stuff
but if you're gonna be living with them
for a while you better be willing to
accept it and if you do need to ask them
to make some sort of change I will sell
you almost fell out of it I wrote a
short story once upon a time called
falling while sitting down it was about
my mother but I think I just felt while
sitting down it's it's in my novel so if
any of you want to read read about the
experience I just had right now falling
out of my chair while sitting down
anyway I think that you need to be
willing to accept that person and not
trying not trying to change the person
but but understand who they are as an
individual get past just tolerating
their stuff because tolerance is a weak
virtue it's a great first step to
understanding a person but ultimately we
need to get to that place of acceptance
and then respect and appreciating that
person for who they are and so let them
know hey I totally accept an in under
stand and I can even appreciate that you
have different needs from me and and
different desires and you know when Ryan
and I lived together he has a bike I
don't need a bike in my house try cuz I
don't I don't go biking but Ryan likes
to go by here is a longboard like I'm
not gonna criticize all that stuff and
in the garage you have a bike and a
longboard no I respect and appreciate
that I think it's great that you have
hobbies like that and that add value to
your life so also realize that the
things that add value to their life just
because they don't add value to yours
doesn't mean that someone else doesn't
truly get value from that and so you
have to be able to be able to willing
you have to be willing to appreciate
that last thing that I'll mention is
with a book called boundaries by dr.
Henry cloud and and I think one thing
that's important when you're first
setting up the living space with that
person set up some boundaries literal
boundaries we've already talked about
your own personal space but but sort of
figurative boundaries in your own
relationship as well and so I would
encourage you to check that out and the
other the last thing that I'll recommend
here for Danny is think about those
common areas that you have think about
those sort of public spaces or semi
public spaces when you go to a public
park it's not always pristine maybe
someone drops a wrapper on the ground
but what do you do you either ignore it
or you pick it up right you pick it up
and you have to sometimes clean up after
other people even people you don't know
and for you this is a semi public space
and you have to go into that semi public
space and and and and treat it like
you're trying to raise the standard of
that space but also realize that public
space is never going to be completely
yours you don't own that public park or
that basketball court or that tennis
court or whatever it may be but you're
still responsible if you're using it
you're responsible for at least
partially for taking care of it
Ryan I love to send her a copy of our
book everything that remains so we were
talking about me and you and Colin we
moved in this house together we called
it the asymmetrical house the a.m house
for short and there's a chapter toward
the end of everything that remains it
talks about that experience of living
together and bringing Colin into our
life and in that transition period we
were moving to a new place as well so
Sean if you could reach out to her and
give her the audiobook version of that
if you like this podcast you're probably
like the audiobook
of everything that remains or if you're
more interested in the physical book or
the e-book we're happy to send those to
you as well Danny our next question is
from Preston in Raleigh North Carolina
the question is for Lyon Ryan you stated
that you are dating Ryan who is not a
minimalist I was just wondering what
that relationship is like because as I
look for a partner I am looking for
someone with similar interests and
philosophies and things like that and I
think minimalism is important so I'm
just wondering give some insight into
what it's like to be with someone who is
not a minimalist
man what does mine and Mariah's
relationship like you know it's funny I
think about how that relationship come
to fruition to fruition and I mean even
before I dated her like I had to work on
me like I had to work on I had to feel I
had to feel like my actions were
aligning with my long-term values and
beliefs when I don't do that
which is how I have lived the majority
of my life unfortunately yeah um
especially in relationships when I do
that it creates a really bad
relationship and before I even really
started looking at having another
serious partner when we moved to Montana
I really had to be clear on how I was
gonna live my life yeah I think I think
if we're not clear then it also attracts
other people who aren't clear yeah
absolutely
yeah that's a great point and I think
that you know with me I found Becks when
I when I stopped looking for someone
else right but I'm glad you just said
what you said because it was after I had
worked on myself for a while to make
sure that I was becoming a better
version of myself I was becoming the
person who I aspired to be and it's not
a perfect person it's not even always an
ideal person but it's the best version
of myself given the resources and one of
those resources is like the time that I
had up until that point right so you're
constantly improving you're constantly
growing and I think that starts to
attract people who are constantly
improving constantly growing and people
who are practical about hey I'm not
looking for the perfect person I'm
looking for a more ideal partner in my
life absolutely I think too the
confidence factors is
we'll really made a difference for me so
when I am when my actions aren't
aligning with my with my values and
beliefs when I am that will make me feel
unsure of myself that will make me not
feel confident right and when I am in a
relationship and I'm not confident when
that person in the relationship like you
said who I've probably attracted who
also is going through a similar type of
conflict I guess self-doubt internal
conflict external conflicts and then
drama right and I every single partner
I've ever had they've they're always
going to say hey you know uh because any
relationship hey I wish that you would
do X more or hey I notice the other day
did Y and I would appreciate if you if
you didn't do that like I think these
are things that will always happen in
fact I think they should happen in
relationships like those conversations
should should happen the problem is that
when my partner would bring something
like that up with me and I'm not
confident I really can't tell whether or
not they are correct does that make
sense man yeah like well I say it seems
to me the the distinction I'm making in
my head right now is you're talking
about sometimes people try to change the
the people in their lives
mm-hmm other times we can try to help
people change their habits and I think
there's a considerable different
solution let me change who you are as a
person you know if I were to like if I
were to go to you in rice that I really
wish you were more of an introvert Ryan
that's that's who you are as a person
you're your extrovert yeah that's part
of your your personality and if I'm
trying to change you as a person that's
not changing the behavior now here's the
thing I also can't change your behaviors
really well all I can do is help you
change the things that you actually want
to change yeah I can I can think of an
actual example the so the girlfriend I
had before Mariah when I was living in
Ohio mm-hmm it got to a point where she
was like hey I saw that on Twitter you
were flirting with Josh's girlfriend it
was your partner at the time uh-huh and
that's inappropriate
and and if you continued it's either you
know either you tone down your Twitter
usage mm-hmm
or uh you and I are through
uh-huh so an insecure Ryan he looks at
that and he's like man maybe she's right
maybe I'm being too flirty maybe maybe
I'm not being a good person right now
but but a confident Ryan can look in the
mirror and say whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
wait a minute I have gone way out of my
way to be as authentic of a person as
possible and that tweet is authentic and
it's not me hitting on Josh's girlfriend
that is not anything other than a you
know me and her bantering back and forth
on Twitter yeah publicly by the way
right um and the fact that you weren't
offended by it tells me a lot too right
the fact that I'm participating right I
mean it so it's a nature it's the nature
of friendship and it seems to me that
that's what she didn't understand that
could be friends with someone without
have it without flirting with it so I
guess what I'm trying to really you know
just help press and understand is that
before you know you go out and find a
partner be make sure that you're good
with yourself make sure that you feel
really really good with how you've been
living your life it's too often Josh
that I would think that having a
girlfriend would solve my problems like
and step it would really compound them
in many respects yeah I can't tell you
how many times like I was you know
single lonely not feeling the best and
just thinking man if I could just have a
girlfriend and then I find a girlfriend
and then yes it just makes it mean
temporarily makes it better right yeah
it's the temporary pain relief which
actually can make something worse if you
if you numb the pain that pain often
helps us grow and helps us get out of
the situation that we're in but if we
temporarily numb the pain that we don't
feel the need to make a change or real
change in our lives right absolutely so
so after I was you know felt felt
confident enough and sure enough that I
could go
Wow and and start dating and you know I
didn't I wasn't really sure that I
wanted to be monogamous I just wanted to
go out and date and see kind of where it
took me and I got on OkCupid / Colin's
request or a recommendation I should say
he didn't request they gonna get on okay
get out of that terrible shower no he
recommended OkCupid because he's he a
long time ago he did a kind of a study
on all the different dating sites and I
will say that I had a lot of good dates
man there's an algorithm on OkCupid I
don't know how it is this is like Mariah
I've been together going on five years
now so the algorithm may have changed
over the last five years right but when
you know five years ago when I was using
it the algorithm was great like when I
could find like an 85% match or above I
felt like I had a decent time at least
at the very at the very least it was it
was a very decent time there was a good
time um but with Mariah God loved her
man she got an OkCupid and I was a first
person she she reached out to I'm like
you have no idea like how lucky you are
to not have to have gone on like 50
dates to like fine whatever right you
have no no idea how lucky you are to
date me Yeah right yeah that's it no you
know what though I would say though man
that her approach to dating was way more
tempered sophisticated a better approach
it was a better approach than what I was
doing obviously right it was more
precise and she weighed the retail and
so here's the other the other maybe she
got lucky but I think she had a good I
think you both got lucky yeah that's a
nice thing I mean the luck is always
going to be a factor on all of this but
you know if even if Luck's half of the
the equation you're responsible for the
other half of the equation right because
if you get really lucky and you're not
prepared for that luck if you're not if
you're not the person you want to be now
here's the other side of that you also
don't want to wait until everything's
perfect in order to find a partner
because it's never going to be all the
way perfect you're never going to be the
perfect version of yourself you're going
to be the best person considering
whatever
circumstances are maybe you're not the
most ideal yet so maybe it's gonna take
some time or whatever to get there but
you'll continue to grow and and you know
what sometimes a partner can get in the
way of that growth if they don't align
with who you are as an individual or
sometimes they can help that growth I
think of me and back side I think's in
in in many ways so it's different from
Brian's situation because Becks I would
consider her a minimalist and in fact in
many respects she's more minimalist than
I am and so she starts questioning my
consumption about certain things as well
and she's certainly much more of an
environmentalist than I am I'm concerned
about the environment I'm concerned
about consumption I'm concerned about
overconsumption I'm concerned about
waste but nowhere near to the extent of
X is right and so it may in fact we were
just me and you and and and podcast
Shawn and and Mariah and Ella and backs
of course we're at the aquarium
yesterday we went over to the Long Beach
aquarium and I had all the things about
like if you make if you don't turn the
water off and you're brushing your teeth
here's how much water it takes when
you're trying to brush your teeth if you
leave it on for twice a day it's you
know like six gallons of water you're
wasting a day or something crazy yeah
Bex is constantly like turn the water
off turn the water off so so she helps
make me a better version of myself
without here's the important part
without judging me ever yeah and without
being passive-aggressive right that's
going to kill a relationship judgment is
going to kill a relationship but if
we're trying to help the other person
become the better version of themselves
because they want to be a better version
of themselves not because I'm trying to
shape them into a better version of what
I think they would be no it's
understanding that okay if I understand
what a better version of Beck's is
because she's done a good job
communicating that to me you know
whether it's the financial side of
things and or the career side of things
I can help her out with that but only
when I know she wants that help and not
forcing someone into help there's I was
listening to a conversation recently I
think it was Johann Hari was talking
about this he he wrote a book called
lost connections and he was talking
about don't help the people if you work
in a nursing home or old person's home
retirement community
any of those places one of the sort of
cardinal rules is you don't go help
someone who doesn't need help you don't
want to do something for someone when
they don't need that help because you're
infantilizing them in a way
yeah dude even if they need the help and
they don't ask for it that's kind of
risky too sometimes totally agree and so
you have to understand I think
understanding the person you live with
over time you understand even they know
if they're not asking explicitly for it
there's sometimes they're implicitly
asking for help and we have to be able
to decipher that and and do so through
effective communication and so I mean
ultimately there's there's a cliche
about you know communication being key
but communicate lack of communication is
what ruins relationships do cliches or
cliché for a reason
whenever I reached out to me and she
sent me an email hey my name is Mariah I
wanna I'm thinking about dating you she
had no profile picture there was nothing
yeah um she was like if you're
interested let me know and I'm like yeah
why not like I'm totally willing to go
on a date we got a good match I had no
idea what she looked like but I'm like
fine no worries she sends me a picture
thank God she was hot but but yeah and
then I you know I sent her a video that
we had recorded from our 2000 and 2013 I
think the Seattle talked that we had an
idea of 2012 but yeah yeah so so I sent
her that talk which was like that's an
hour 45 minute long video man yeah she
watched the whole thing she got to know
who you were really really got to know
who I was I communicated very clearly
who I was and how I lived my life yeah
and then when we started dating I did
exactly what you said man I held back
any judgment of Mariah it was it was her
and I just going on dates having some
tea look into each other's eyes getting
lost no III slowly but surely started to
really really just love the person that
Mariah was she is just absolutely
perfect for me and when I when I you
know saw her house for the first time in
her room yeah dude a lot of shoes maybe
more clothes in the closet than I would
have but for all intensive purposes she
was it
not overflowing and I did not feel like
it was a hoarder it was a situation I
could look at and say you know what
she's not a minimalist I certainly
certainly wouldn't have you know this
many pairs of shoes but this is not
something that I could not live with
it's something I can understand yeah
it's not it's something I understand
it's something that I can I can respect
and and not just that but appreciate the
difference is that her and I have in
fact you know her I think she probably
probably would call herself a minimalist
now she kind of I think she's scared to
call herself in there it's a stark term
a it really is but but um but but
regardless though man whether she calls
herself a minimalist or not she has gone
way out of her way to support me and
dude it's funny you were talking about
Bex being more of an environmentalist
yeah if Mariah she is always reminding
Lake just small things like we're gonna
get coffee she's like oh let's not
forget our thermoses yeah or um you know
we got a like that clear shower curtain
yeah and oh my god this thing is dirty
we're gonna have to like replace this
every every three months she's like no
no no no she's like we're not gonna
waste that much plastic every three
months I'm like oh yeah you're right
that's really really stupid but but I
guess what I'm trying to say here is is
that it's it's completely possible so
from the other side of it from Riya side
of it it's completely possible to not be
a minimalist but still support someone
who is right and and I think Danny like
that's that's Reza
oh I'm sorry Preston Danny was the last
one yeah
Preston what I'm saying is is that it is
completely possible for you to find
someone who isn't a minimalist to have a
great relationship but you know make
sure that you are acting in alignment
with your values and beliefs that you
feel good about yourself first before
you even start to bring someone else
into your life but but you know the old
the old was I guess it's not an old a
Pithom because you and I I think you and
I maybe invented this apathy the new app
the new app of home I would I would I
would just encourage Preston to raises
standards and lowers expectations and
what I mean by that is is like be
yourself let people know who you
do not develop relationships with people
who who are clearly out of alignment
with your values and beliefs if you find
someone who is in alignment with your
values and beliefs put everything you
can into that relationship but do not
have any expectations on what you're
going to get back because you might put
a lot of effort into a relationship and
someone might not treat you as well
that's okay that's not the end of the
world that's that's where you can you
can you know have an exit plan or an
exit ramp put that relationship and move
on to the next one yeah you don't have
to continue enabling an abusive or you
know the continuing enabling an abusive
relationship or it's a relationship that
takes advantage of you if you feel like
you're being used and take that as good
news that you're a useful person and but
also realize that you can cut ties from
that you know if people are trying to
play the victim role they're being
victimized errs or or they're hurt and
they're trying to hurt you you know
there's hurt people hurt people right
right and so I think we want to steer
clear of that and the best way to steer
clear of that is to know yourself and
understand who you are as a person
because once you understand that then
you'll attract people who are more like
the person that you want to attract yeah
and I mean honestly like I don't know
why Mariah treats me so well I wish I
had this magic bullet answer to say hey
here's what I do - - to make Mariah feel
like she wants to treat me the same way
because I certainly been in a
relationship where I've been just as
kind to two other people and have not
got it back so I think luck has a lot to
do with Mariah knives relationships sure
but ultimately Mariah and I are giving
as much as possible we are respecting
each other as much as possible we are
supporting each other as much as
possible and and we don't hold a count
either that's that's a huge thing yeah
Preston I'd love to send you a copy of
our book minimalism live a meaningful
life there's an entire chapter in that
book about relationships and really the
three different types of relationships
we bring into our lives the the primary
the secondary and the
the peripheral relationships that we
have in our lives and really
reprioritizing those relationships so
that we spin the appropriate amount of
time with those people and then finding
out about the the people in our lives
what are their values what are my values
helping you establish what those values
are so Shawn if you can reach out to him
give him the audio book or the book book
or the eBook version whatever he wants I
would greatly appreciate it and before
we move on to the lightning round we'd
love to hear what you have to say so if
you have a comment or a tip about people
or relationships or anything else
including advice for any of our callers
today leave us a voicemail for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine you
can also email a voice memo right from
your phone to podcast at the minimalists
comm what are our favorite comments and
tips on a future episode Ryan what time
is it you know what time it is it is
time for our lightning round where we
answer questions from social media and
did we do we do indeed are we are on
Twitter and Facebook and Instagram at
the minimalists during the lightning
round this is where Ryan and I both do
our best to answer each question with
just a short shareable less than 140
character response we'll also put the
text to these minimal Maxim's in the
show notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you'd
like and now you can find all of our
quotes in one place minimal maxims calm
alrighty our first question is from
Angela how do you minimize the people
from your life who bring you down a peg
whenever they can especially when
they're in your family or in your
workplace those are the worst people to
spend time with man yeah because the
people that dragged you damage and you
do get dragged down and guess what else
happens you Spencer loves company man
yeah yeah so pull up a chair and stay
awhile right there's a line from from
everything that remains is yeah
misery encourages others to pull up a
chair and stay awhile and and that's
really and you start once you get
miserable then you start trying to tear
other people down as well and it's a
perpetuating cycle and it seems to be
never-ending except you can't end it
well it's crazy like when anyone it
whenever someone tries to turn me down a
peg it's usually what they're implicitly
saying is
I have a problem I don't know how to fix
it you look like you're living a really
good life right but the way that you're
living doesn't seem like it could fix my
problem right so therefore you're living
a terrible life
yeah and I'm miserable and the way that
you fix your problems aren't gonna work
to fix my problems yeah and all I can do
is look at that and say okay sorry that
sorry that you know my words aren't
gonna help you or my example isn't gonna
help you and then I have to walk away
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna feed that
dialogue much yeah and that walking away
is important so my pithy answer for
Angela is distance creates the room
necessary to let go I think sometimes
what happens here is it's really hard
especially if you have this primary
relationship in your life a family
member or my life I creating that
distance is so important in the the
removal of that relationship and what
does that mean it means not proactively
reaching out to them it means supporting
them if they absolutely need support but
not supporting them when they're just
playing the victim role when they're
just looking for attention if their
attention seeking doesn't mean they
actually need help I think back to Ella
our four-year-old who she's constantly
seeking attention now she's four she
doesn't have the prefrontal cortex to
understand why I'm not going to help her
necessarily but I'm teaching her the
lessons of I will give you direction I
will help you if you truly need help but
I'm not going to carry your book bag for
you when you can carry it yourself and
and when she starts to understand that
she develops the musculature to to make
that change now when we're dealing with
adults like that what they're but what
they're gonna understand is oh this
person isn't gonna help me if I don't
actually need help you're creating that
distance and so loving them it is is
important but that doesn't mean that you
have to tolerate their Mis behaviors
right and so my second pithy answer is
one that you've heard a million times
but it's so important and it's you can't
change the people around you but you can
change the
people around you and maybe another way
to think about that is if this person
this is hypothetical person you're
talking about or the specific person
angela is talking about if they weren't
in your life right now would you go out
of your way to bring that person into
your life here's what I'll tell you I
can tell you with Ryan if you weren't in
my life right now yes of course I would
go out of my way to bring you into my
life we have a great relationship it's a
type of relationship I want
Oh same with Sean and with back I don't
know about Harding come on I'm just
gonna say shot hard I how about Sean
Mahalo oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah Sean
Harding High School no right there
that's a really good way to look at it
man that's a really good way to look at
it and I think that and that's even true
with family members so so maybe here's
something else that else that that the
blood doesn't equal family you know
something like that when I think about
just because you share you know some of
the same strands of DNA or whatever I
have half-brothers and sisters out there
whom I have not talked to regularly my
entire life
and that's okay and it doesn't mean
they're bad people it doesn't mean I'm
judging them it just means that I choose
to surround myself with people who share
similar values to me they're gonna be
different beliefs quite often I think
that's an important thing to to think
about here Ryan you and I have different
beliefs
Sean you and I have different beliefs
that's okay those are different paths to
get us to whatever that destination that
we're going to is and that means we have
the the same values to and maybe
different paths to get there yeah my pet
the answer is it's possible to show love
and support from any distance so I think
we're pretty much saying the same thing
Josh when I have someone in my life who
is constantly bringing me down a peg I
will let them know I don't know if you
know this or not but you're constantly
negative when you and I talk it is not
an uplifting conversation in fact I
usually feel bad after we talk so I just
have to tell you that if we start to
have a conversation and I start to feel
bad I'm gonna have to end that
conversation and it's nothing against
you it's just that I I have a problem
with with having a lot of negative
conversation
in my life I wish I could be there to to
support you more but but IIIi can't sit
there and listen to a bunch of negative
things if you ever need something
specifically yeah reach out to me if you
have a true emergency you think true
emergency or need something specifically
I would be more than happy to to help
you out but when the conversation starts
- usually I'll point it out when the
conversation starts to get because
that's time to do it you know you don't
want to wait - seven days later where
all of a sudden hey you were that
conversation we could go at 2:00 p.m. I
wrote it down here in my journal right
no you want to because they're in that
state right then I think the opposite is
also true Ryan we also want to make sure
that we're not that person and really a
definitely I have to catch myself and
I'll apologize sometimes like I will say
like you know I've had I've had a
headache for the last month and so I'm
going to this doctor tomorrow to to do
some tests but I found myself with
having this like you know the this
physical sensation of and it tears me
down and I find that like I'm not the
nicest version of myself when I have
like a really bad headache and so like
yesterday with with Becks when we were
we were like driving over to to your
apartment to pick you up I had a
headache I said hey look I know I'm not
being myself right now I apologize I'm
not the best version of myself I'm sorry
if I'm complaining at all I don't mean
to complain I don't mean the vent to you
and I really do appreciate your support
just letting that person know that Haley
I'm not in my optimal view it's me yeah
yeah and it's not you you're not doing
anything wrong I just want you to know
that if I'm if I'm acting a little bit
out of character it's not intentional
it's just I've got something else going
on right now and setting that that
expectation with them lets them know
like oh okay like there's this little
temporary period the problem is when
it's prolonged if that person is always
acting like that you've got this this
protracted rage or anger or this cascade
of emotions all the time this cascade of
drama in our lives we want to go to
disconnect from that and I think the way
we do that is by creating the distance
and and and there's nothing wrong with
them and like people they might feel
guilty for doing that they they might
feel like they're abandoning a friend or
a family
by creating a little bit of distance if
you are if you are going out of your way
to make yourself miserable to bring
yourself down out of guilt yeah that is
just think about that think about it
that's what you're doing think about
that it's it's not it's not the end of
the world to create a little bit a
little bit of distance what I'll say to
man is I've done this before with people
and nine times out of ten man they it
comes back like the relationship will be
mended yeah um I have had people where
yes I have I have distanced myself and
made it very clear with them hey we're
family I love you I am I am happy to
support you you know everything I just
said I you know went on my way to tell
them and then eventually you know the
law will send me a tax hey how's it
going hey I saw this and thought about
you and and all of a sudden like the
relationship has started to change you
created that distance and you didn't
have to say I am creating this distance
for you they it it becomes implicit in a
way because you know that that if you
start stop communicating with someone
for a longer period of time or you you
stop going out of your way with them
what happens is they come back around
quite often it doesn't always happen and
maybe the distance P grows farther and
that's okay too
and you learn a lot about yourself you
learn a lot about the relationship in
general but but creating that distance
doesn't have to be I doesn't have to be
some really difficult conversation it's
just simply stepping back and then
stepping back again and and walking away
slowly from that relationship in a way
that that really fuels you to be a
better version of yourself yeah
absolutely all right Lilly wants to know
how do you start developing closer
relationships with people once you get
rid of physical clutter and get over the
fear you might have of trying to do just
that well I have a short answer for you
it's sort of like this it's a it's a
spin-off of a popular bumper sticker I
think this one is no values no self no
your values know yourself and so the
first no is spelled with you know right
if you have no values you have no
self like you don't have a definitive
identity because you your if your values
are so fluid then you can be anything
and by being anything you are nothing
right you have no no sort of an identity
but if you know your values KN Oh W know
your values then you know yourself me
and it's sort of the thing you were
talking about earlier with Preston's
question Ryan you're talking about man I
had to had to get my own house in order
before I started trying to bring anyone
else into that house both literally and
and that's a great way of looking at
like an actual house right so if you if
you have a house that is is unfinished
like you're not gonna bring a partner in
there to live with you you're gonna
finish that house first and now I mean
we're obviously talking about a
metaphorical house sure um but I think
that's a great example may thinking
about it as looking at yourself as a
house that you're preparing to bring
someone in to live with you yeah and
once you know those values well once you
know what your values are it is possible
for you it's more possible for you to
connect so much more deeply with other
people it's not just surface level
connection it's not this facade of of
chemistry and attractiveness and and
shared interest like oh yeah shared
proximity right if there's something
much deeper and because there's
something that is much deeper in common
you're able to you were able to connect
and that connection is a lot longer last
thing I can think of myself like when I
when I didn't really know what my values
were so I think especially back to the
corporate days I was able to connect
with anyone but it was very surface
level right because I said yes anything
and it was because I was so fluid right
I didn't
I had no value so I had no self and I
was just ping-pong from relationship to
relationship friendship the friendship
acquaintance to acquaintance networking
buddy to the networking buddy and we're
all these sort of ephemeral
relationships that didn't have much
meaning to them because it was just
there it's whatever was in front of me
and I think about it now especially
having a four year old and it's like
well that's all four year old acts it's
like ping-pong in from moment to moment
to moment to moment and everything is
sort of an emergency everything is is
urgent but whenever
thing is urgent nothing is urgent that's
that's pithy for you Shawn write that
one down for the shownotes yeah also the
other thing that I think about here when
Lily's question is how do you start
developing closer relationships with
people one thing that has helped me out
a lot is people tell you who they are
either through their words or through
their actions right and when people
gossip to you they gossip about you amen
and so think about that if all of a
sudden your relationship was predicated
on gossip or if your gossiping to other
people you're not the kind of person I
want in my life
now here's a weird thing gossip actually
played a really important role for many
millennia in tribes but it's it's no
longer as relevant in our everyday lives
right so if I'm if I'm going behind your
back to say something or if I'm talking
about Shawn behind his back to you
here's the thing I better be willing to
say that - Shawn
absolutely and if I'm not willing to say
that - Shawn that tells you a lot about
me because I'm gonna be doing the same
thing to you let me do the same thing to
her and him and her and and so if
someone gossips to you they're going to
gossip about you that's not the type of
person I want to bring in my life and
say mister with all their other actions
if they're behaving a particular way to
someone else they're probably gonna
behave that way too you think about that
when you're bringing new people into
your life my short answer is this Josh
do the things you love make friends
along the way
approaching it in the reverse way can be
more difficult so I think me personally
it's often that I was so worried about
bringing relationships in my life
whether it was a romantic partner or
whether it was being like the cool kid
in high school that I never actually did
anything that I loved I was so focused
on doing what the things that other
people loved for example um in high
school I really looked up to actually
even in junior I looked up to the
skaters we had a friend who skated yeah
so I looked up to him and was like wow
that's really cool I want to skate and I
did have a lot of fun skateboarding
don't get me wrong but I skateboarded
because the cool kids were skateboarding
and that's who I wanted to hang out with
now it turns out I actually did like
that right but there are so many other
times in my life where I've taken that
approach in
not worked right if I were to mend am
into that a little bit I would probably
say do things you find meaningful and
the cool thing is that you actually
found a significant amount of meeting
with the skateboarding side of things
not at first and maybe your reason for
getting into it was the wrong reason but
then you were able to sort of fashion it
into this meaningful experience in this
connection and so are you rephrasing
this because we're taking back the word
love no I think doing something you love
here is important but I think it's more
important if you're doing something you
find meaningful it I am able to separate
that from some of this just exciting
quite often when we say do things you
love sometimes it's just like yeah I
really love you some activity whatever
I'm a yoga yoga that's that can be
really meaningful so like it kind of
just depends like sometimes we just do
things that are exciting in the moment
so what you're saying is is don't
conflate right meaning and excitement
yes I totally understand that dude I
totally agree with that so that's that's
another pithy add so don't conflate
meaning and excitement yeah it's good
man you know Cruz Spence the dating
coach on the on the mentoring page that
we have man What did he say he said
girls love men who are interesting and
it's absolutely true if you are if you
are doing things that are exciting or
maybe they are meaningful whatever it is
people are going to take note of that
and also you're gonna pick up friends
along the way so again if you want to
make more friends I would say just keep
being yourself don't make you no friends
this top priority focus on doing what
what you focus on living your life and
if you can if you can do that then it's
not only our gonna make friends a lot
easier along the way but the friends
that you make in your life are going to
be they're gonna be really really
outstanding relationships if you
approach it that way yeah I agree I
think I think people love people who are
interesting right and and I think living
a meaningful life is one of them
interesting I truly interesting like oh
I am interested in doing that everyone
wants to live a meaningful life not just
fascinated so we that's another thing we
can fly we can fly being fascinated by
something like oh well he did a great
skateboarding trick that's fascinating
but I may not find it truly interesting
like Wow a meaningful life like I am
interested in living might the best
version myself so when you say be
yourself what you're really saying is be
the best version of yourself and people
will find that interesting because you
are living a meaningful life yeah
I really like that all right we should
oh we got one more question here Ryan
geo is asking people often mistake oh
man this is gonna be good good for me
because I'm interested to hear your
thoughts on it too so people often
mistake my introverted personality as
rude how do I explain to people that I
don't want to talk to them without being
rude this problem has affected me in the
workplace and has actually prevented me
from moving up or getting raises at work
and so if you want our answer to that
each week Ryan and I we do the
minimalists private podcast it's
exclusively for our patreon supporters
we keep the supply cast 100%
advertisement free so it is a hundred
percent listener supported each week we
recorded and we record a bonus podcast
it's called the minimalist private
podcast it shows up right there in your
podcast feed so you don't have to get on
the Internet
you don't have to go to some website I
forgot what was my passcode to send me
an email to give them my passcode and
all this up no no no you just have a
link once you're a patreon supporter so
you just go over to the minimalists com
click donate at the top you become a
regular supporter you get access to all
of our monthly live streams it's called
ask the minimalists anything we're also
going to do a video tour of this
beautiful new studio space that we're in
exclusively for our patreon supporters
we're also putting out a bunch of live
events for our patreon supporters you
get first access to tickets to any new
live events we do plus all the
recordings of the live events those are
patreon exclusives as well we just put
out the Philadelphia one the DC one is
is coming really soon
Tampa's out there the Detroit is out
there with Colin right so there's I mean
there are dozens of private podcasts
right now so if you
can't get enough of the minimalist we're
gonna answer Gio's question this week
but then we're also going to have a lot
of other meaningful creations out there
on the minimalist private podcast it
allows us to sort of put our hair down a
little bit because there's only a few
thousand people over there that support
us and here's the thing I realized that
some of you can't afford to support this
podcast we want to make it a hundred
percent free for you and that's why it's
out there it's free it's advertisement
free we're not cluttering this thing
with ads but many of you can afford to
support this and if you can that makes
this a sustainable model that allows us
to continue to create meaningful
creations for you you've helped us build
this beautiful studio space and we're
really appreciative of that and it's
about one percent of our audience
actually a little less than one percent
of our audience that supports this
podcast and if we can get it higher than
if we can get two or five percent of the
audience that supports this podcast then
it really helps our simple living
message reach more people because the
money doesn't go to me and Ryan it
allows us to pay a podcast producer it
allows us to add a video component to
the podcast as well so pretty soon we're
going to do a video version of the
podcast you can subscribe to our YouTube
channel the minimalists com you can
click on the youtube link there at the
top or just go to youtube.com slash the
minimalist if you want the video version
of this podcast which is coming soon but
it's made possible by you we we really
need your help because we're not going
to clutter this thing with
advertisements so if you're willing to
support us at any level if you want to
give us you know a hundred dollars a
month that's up to you if you say you
know I can just afford a dollar or two
per episode that we really appreciate
the support either way you could also
contribute one time if you go over to
the minimalists com you click donate at
the top PayPal or Vimeo options are over
there as well but if you become a
regular supporter you get access to all
of the live events all the live streams
the weekly private podcast where we
answer everyone's questions we call it
the the PostScript episode so we
basically do this this PS episode we're
gonna answer Geo's questions this week
about introversion and how do we deal
with people as an introvert now Ryan I'm
interested to hear in your take because
you're the the extreme extrovert of the
duo and I could go live on an island by
myself for a few years and and I think
I'd be pretty contented at least for a
while
well I'll tell you what's definitely
going to make its way into this answer
is you when you're around people when
we're around people you will come across
as more extroverted yeah that's what
I've heard than you yeah exactly
isn't that strange we'll definitely talk
about that so yeah if you want to join
us over there you just become a patreon
patron patreon patron say that 15 times
fast yeah and you'll get access to all
the archives as well we have dozens of
past PostScript episodes you can check
out live events pass live streams and a
lot more video creations coming for you
as well all right well now it's time for
our added value portion of the show this
is where we each talk about something
that has added value to our lives
recently Ryan what has added value to
your life recently dude we were out with
the bergamont they have opened up for us
at least once and Grand Rapids yeah
they're a great band great husband and
wife duo the bergamot yeah they got they
got a great song actually this put my
first recommendation is this great song
that they have it's called forget about
tomorrow
great single we'll put the link to that
too that actually it's not a single
what's on their album which their album
is great but that's like one of my
favorite songs on that album but they
they were talking about this coffee kit
that they had yeah and I remember you
were really really excited about it
but it doesn't boil the water so it's
like it does everything but it boils the
water but dude I got it because it is
it's about the size of a thermos hmm I
can make a 10 ounce cup of coffee pretty
simple so between that thermos sized a
pour-over kit and the boiler or the the
kettle the portable kettle that I have
I've been able to save about 30% of my
room of the room in my coffee kit which
that doesn't sound like a whole lot like
I have 30% of a coffee it this is not
like like a lot but when you're
minimalist and I'm really trying to pack
only I'm just gonna fill the packed bag
mm-hmm and bring that to Australia I'm
not gonna do a second little book bag
I'm not gonna do anything else I'm like
really challenging myself to because I'm
gonna be gone for five weeks maybe I
think maybe even six weeks
um so that little 30% of the room that I
just saved in my in my coffee kit very
huge for me and it works really really
well podcast Sean can attest to it I
made him a cup of coffee out of it not
too bad
yeah it's what's a call it's called the
Calphalon oh and that will be an shall
make sure to put that in the show notes
it is it I mean I think it's a
game-changer you're right dude if they
could somehow incorporate a heating
element in there to to heat the water
that would like that would be a perfect
product but it's about it's near perfect
yet so Brent you have to bring the
kettle with you and I think for me the
reason it doesn't it doesn't and that's
why this is like a perfect illustration
of the added value section we're not
recommending things to other people
necessarily it allows us to talk about
things that have added value to our
lives and the thing that adds value to
my life may not add value to yours and
vice versa so I'm getting ready to
recommend a book and a playlist here and
they may not add value to your life at
all and that goat that holds true for
our audience it's like hey you may or
may not find value that you there's
someone listening to this right now who
doesn't like coffee yes and then this
thing is far less valuable for them than
it would be for even me so what do you
I'm in well I'm just thinking about the
the the the coffee kit that you're
talking about there for me like I tend
to use the the mugs that are already in
a hotel room when we're traveling or if
it's an air B&B so I don't need the cup
that's in there I don't travel with a a
cup generally because I just used the
the washable mugs or or you know
whatever's in the hotel in fact
sometimes I could go downstairs and get
a mug from them I and and yeah they have
a little paper cups in hotel room and
I'll use that in a pinch if necessary
but I actually prefer having coffee in a
a nice ceramic mug and so it's just in
the pour over like it's about the same
size as a traveling v60 pour over and so
it doesn't save me a whole lot of space
but I can see for you because you're not
carrying the extra cups and everything
else how it's going to save you some
space for sure I'm gonna recommend a
book our friend Sean mihalick who I was
just jokingly talking about earlier he's
a talented young writer he's also the
editor of paleo magazine but he's a
novelist and he's I think this is his
fourth book and I've really enjoyed all
his past work
about a chapter into this new book and
so far so good it is the strangest story
it's called the dissection of
vertebrae's and it's really about a
young man who gets married and is trying
to find himself sexually but also in
terms of his relationships and so this
episode is about people and I thought it
was a great idea to mention a book where
it's like we're all searching and I
think all the commonality between these
questions we had today is someone who is
searching for better more meaningful
more connected relationships in a way
that they don't experience it right now
and I think this book is about about
exactly that it's a novel it's called
the dissection of vertebrae's we'll put
a link to that in the show notes and
then there's a playlist I've been
listening to its Thom Yorke in fact we
were listening to it we were driving to
the aquarium yesterday and and you were
talking about in your apartment how oh
yeah I was so yet so there's a noise
going on in my apartment yeah and I
recorded it to send to the the
maintenance guy of our building and I
was playing it for you and backs yes and
it to me it sounded something like
something Thom Yorke would listen to
yeah on his iPod verbatim you said this
sounds like an intro to a Radiohead song
right and then you put on King of Limbs
but before that I don't you may not even
realize what was playing in the car
because there were seven of us or six of
us in the car
yesterday I had this Thom Yorke playlist
on now these aren't his songs these are
songs that he listens to and the best
way I can describe it it's like if
you're at home and your walls were
bleeding music it would it's the ambient
sound of of home in a way that is so odd
and I can't even do it justice but it's
this time your playlist it's on Apple
music and we'll put a link to it in the
show notes but I will listen to it at
home now because it adds this ambience
and some of us not even music sometimes
there's five minutes of silence and it
just feels like the walls in your house
are talking to you you know
not in a way where I feel like I have
some sort of mental illness but in a way
where I'm like oh my goodness like this
feels like the sounds of home and so
check it out and Ryan you got anything
else oh wait we should probably move on
to two right here right now
yeah you've already talked about your
weight value you're getting caught in a
loop a menu where we went to dinner the
other night with the bergamont yeah so
right here right now so we're talking
about what's going on in the lives of
the minimalists if you want the show
notes to these episodes so Ryan and I we
do this podcast every week if you if you
want the show notes show up right in
your email inbox just head on over to
our website the minimalists com at the
top you can enter your email address so
anytime we put out a new podcast episode
all of the show notes everything we
talked about today are in the show notes
over on our website but also will show
they'll show up right in your your email
inbox any time we write something new as
well so any new essay that comes out
will show up in your inbox
no spam ever because that stuff sucks we
already talked about all the ways you
can support the podcast I just want to
say thanks real quick to all of our
patreon supporters you're the reason we
can keep doing this doing this in this
beautiful space and allowing us to
expand out into the video side of things
over on YouTube as well and that's all I
got right now Ryan you got anything else
for us yeah dude I got all these
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners check them out hi my name is
Sarah Powell and I am from Boise Idaho I
was just going to buy cider that is
video on Netflix about a year and a half
ago and the next day after that I had my
own packing party and packed down my
house
I'm also a mom has two small kids I just
got finished listening to your guys's
podcast about being a minimalist with
kids I have found that I do a lot less
cleaning since there's a lot less stuff
for my kids to make a mess with I've
also found that my kids use their
imaginations more and after you get the
use out of the toys that they do have as
far as like gifts and stuff like that
I've asked my family to give them
experiences so we have like a year path
to the zoo a year path to our one of our
local museums here
stuff like that are always great gift
ideas hi Joshua and Ryan my name is
Kiana iruo I'm from Portland Oregon
I got tons of value from your critics
episode the ability to laugh at yourself
shows tremendous humility and reminded
me not to take myself so seriously I
thought it was great ammunition for the
critics as a fairly new follower of the
minimalist I have been highly aware of
how much I have what needs to go and
what I really need to add value and
simplicity to my life as a person who
struggles with anxiety I realized that
having too much stuff definitely adds
stress to my life I want to thank you
for your practical advice and
encouragement
hello I am Maria and I'm calling from
Stockholm Sweden I am a huge fan of you
guys after watching your documentary on
Netflix after that both me and my
husband is really hooked on minimalism
we are trying to get our kids that way
but that is a bit harder but we'll get
there my response is for Stephanie on
episode 114 which I loved by the way it
was so funny she says that she loves
shopping and look for bargains for her
family but as a stressed out and tired
mom myself I kind of responded to her
question where she said I have to do
everything because I can really relate
to that and as for shopping goes
obviously we have to buy clothes and
stuff for our kids and toilet paper and
whatever which is really nice if it's at
bargain prices and I as well look for it
even though I call myself a minimalist
but I think in her case perhaps it's the
fact that maybe she doesn't have to do
everything herself
perhaps her family and her kids and her
husband can pitch in and and you guys
can all do together
because it is really hard to be the one
responsible for everything and believe
me I know I have been there and I
crashed and burned and now we actually
all have to pitch in so that I will not
do that again and also ask friends and
your community for help you know
watching kids and just give yourself a
break and take care of yourself because
you are really important for your family
and I think they find it so much more
important to have you healthy instead of
having like really cheap toilet paper so
I wish you all the best of luck all
right Joe that's it for this episode if
you have a question for the minimalists
give us a call for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo right from your phone
to podcast at the minimalists comm and
if you leave here with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening yeah we'll see you
next time